[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
Kos and as you can see over my shoulder
ah we have an exciting dude and the
Punisher
this is XM's Punisher the comic version
a lot of you guys are used to right now
are the Netflix version but you also
understand there was four different
versions spanning multiple years and as
you can see they range from even dolph
lundgren that actually played the
Punisher and that goes all the way back
to 1989 and the character was always
depicted frank castle you know the story
his family was murdered he was a
ex-marine Green Beret trained well and
the Punisher always struck a chord with
the hard-working oppressed man that his
family and life is struck by violence by
no fault of his own he win he fought for
our country came back and he wanted to
live his life with his children he did
his tour he did his duty and to have his
family murdered in front of his very
eyes over a mob hit gone awry
he he had the tools and he was trained
in military preparation to go exact his
revenge now in the comic books the first
time the Punisher showed up it was in
spider-man 129 I believe 129 and 126 and
he was brainwashed by the jackal who
sent him out to get spider-man he was a
mercenary we didn't know too much about
Frank Castle during the character was
introduced and then they started to
flesh out the character later on we
found out that he was an antihero
because Marvel was tooling with the
character he had the white boots and the
black and white accents you know the
whole uniform the stuff that I like you
know the piercing you know we can't get
that now what the future iterations of
the character did you know with stuff
like warzone they made Frank a real big
strong man because you have to
understand he doesn't have any
superpowers he's just a very good
tactician very good at firearms knives
any type of hand-to-hand combat
the Q the Q C P I believe it's called um
he is proficient in all types of
military martial arts
so Frank Castle can handle his own but
then you have to have him go up against
a superhero's so you have to make him
work in this world and I always thought
the movies encapsulated that wealth you
know every last movie took their own
iteration of it they kept the core story
of he was wrong his family is wrong they
were murdered and he would want to
revenge on a mob remember at this time
the
bob was a big thing in New York City so
this character was made out of the
frustrations that uh New Yorkers I guess
was you know filling at the hands of the
mob so here's the Punisher the character
took on he had his only got his own book
that his own series and after they got
his own series they did a whole bunch of
mini series and he teamed them up with
your greatest superheroes it was even a
time where you know he basically almost
killed daredevil you know um so Frank
castles always walked that line of
morality and immorality you know he he
always threaded the needle in his own
personal street justice you know Frank
Castle was that guy who you Lou if it
was a tough call to make
he was gonna make the call regardless of
feelings involved because he has like
zero emotions now I love the way that
the Netflix series has flushed out the
character
I don't per se like the actor that plays
him now I would love the actor that
played him if he was stronger taller you
know a more robust man to handle the
role but what he lacks in stature he
more than makes up for it in enthusiasm
and acting chops I mean he is by far out
of the all four of them he is by far the
best iteration of the Punisher now the
The Punisher war zone the man who played
The Punisher war zone this punishment
that guy had the absolute look I thought
that movie nailed everything that it is
to be Frank Castle now we don't did the
backstory of Frank Castle let's get into
statue though you are here for this
statue you lie here to hear about a
story about the Punisher this XM statue
the reason why I love XM I think XM is
the pinnacle of statutes the the from
the shipping boxes to the way that their
velcro strapped in to the way they're
meticulously packed till the fact that
they make sure that your package is
gonna get to you with zero breakage 100%
attention to detail all right as you can
see is mixed-media when you have the the
strap along his shoulder that's holding
his his gun and the leather strap that
is across the back of the motorcycle as
you can see here with that holds the
ammo and more guns you see the water
puddle in the pictures the bike is
meticulously put together Frank himself
looks strong
he looks current he doesn't have it's
timeless is the timeless piece the fact
that the motorcycle 2 gives you so much
to look at it wasn't an afterthought
actually in a motorcycle was probably
the prime piece and it this is my first
statue that has a vehicle and I'm so
happy that it was an XM Punisher I
wanted to get a Punisher statue and I
thought this was the definitive statute
to get now an L so has to portrait heads
so it has the war zone one that I really
loved the one with the bellman bandaid
on his nose and it has the the more
traditional Frank Castle with the
slicked hair and curl that's in the
front as you can see right here
this statue it's it's was my second X M
statue then I received the first one was
iron fist this was the second and the
third one was named or having more X M
statues on pre-order that's actually
coming and I will debut on this song on
this channel but Frank castles are moved
Frank Castle is exactly what I guess the
city needed when they had the plague of
the mob and how Marvel stretched that
out to give you a deeper understanding
of this character with the Netflix
series that that made me so happy
because he wasn't a one-dimensional gun
to higher and are also translated well
into the comic books whereas you know
Frank Castle can now hold his own
standing next to the likes of Wolverine
and Captain America and Frank Castle is
one character to be filled so without
further ado I give you the Punisher by
XM studios light follow and subscribe
tune in to IOP on Sundays at 1:00 p.m.
and also for the Lords of gaming dotnet
we have all the news on the latest video
games opinion pieces and also tune in to
the last word with loyal Cognito
any bonta's with all this lunar shooters
information that's going down right now
you have division 2 dropping a raid
you have destiny back kickin it again
you have anthem screaming it's
scratching trying to survive so tune in
as we give you all this information and
trust kos will be here next week with
another outstanding staff
thank you again I appreciate every last
one of you that Tunes in and checks out
these statues that I love so much
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]